A wise man once said, "Everybody poops."
Well that should probably be changed to everything
poops, because all living things excrete waste.
This brings us to a brilliant question posed
by a subscriber called George, whose head
we’d love to crack open and see what’s
going on inside- do trees poop?
As it so happens, yes they do, though there
is a bit of a semantic argument to be had
over what one might consider "tree poop."
(A sentence I've never in my life thought
I'd have need to utter.)
To begin with, all living things excrete things
they no longer need or which otherwise might
be harmful to them if allowed to build up
in said being's system- yes, everything from
the lowliest single celled organisms to blue
whales do this.
In fact, a microbe known as Paramecium caudatum
has been observed passing solid, liquid and
gaseous waste, meaning it technically poops,
pees and farts, despite its entire being consisting
of a single cell.
So what exactly do trees excrete?
Well, although trees produce very little in
terms of pure waste, due to tremendously efficient
metabolic systems that convert most everything
the plants take in into something they can
make use of (and a generally good nutrient
acquisition system that ensures many things
that would otherwise be bad for the plants
aren't taken in at all), nothing is perfect
and trees will invariably need to excrete
a number of things to remain healthy- the
most well known of course being oxygen.
Now oxygen, which the tree, like any aerobic
life form, does need but invariably has an
excess amount of as a natural byproduct of
photosynthesis, is mostly expired, along with
other gaseous waste, through small pores in
the leaves of a tree known as stomata.
Trees also excrete water vapour containing
various other waste products during this process.
While this is an excretion, you may not consider
this akin to pooping and peeing, perhaps more
like breathing.
After all, humans expel carbon dioxide, water
vapour and certain other substances while
breathing.
So what's something the tree does that is
more like pooping and peeing?
In regards to the latter, some, but not all,
plants occasionally expel water and other
waste via a process known as guttation.
In a nutshell, guttation occurs when excess
water is taken into the roots resulting in
an upwards pressure within the tree that must
be gotten rid of; this most commonly occurs
at night when the stomata are generally closed,
robbing the tree of one way it may get rid
of such excess water.
The result of this root pressure is a sticky
sap, consisting of sugar, water, and various
other substances, including waste compounds,
being pushed out of water stomata or hydathodes
in the leaves.
What about tree pooping?
Plant cells contain large vacuoles that are
variously used either to store essential nutrients
or waste the plant no longer has use for.
In regards to the latter waste, plants concentrate
it in parts of its anatomy that, while also
potentially serving other purposes throughout
those parts' lifecycle, are nonetheless “destined
to fall off or die”, like leaves, petals,
or even fruit.
The waste, which in turn sometimes also serves
a useful purpose but nonetheless must be gotten
rid of lest it build up and ultimately harm
the tree, including things like heavy metals,
tannins, oxalates, and anthocyanins, will
naturally be lost come wintertime for many
trees or just at random times throughout the
year for evergreens.
As famed biologist Brian J. Ford notes, "the
leaf... not only [is] the plant’s photosynthetic
centre, but also [is] the organ which, at
the end of its anabolic programme, is stripped
of vital constituents and systematically charged
with metabolic wastes."
As a noteworthy example of this, mangroves
are able to thrive in saltwater, despite too
much salt being harmful for the plant and
that they otherwise don't need large amounts
of salt to survive.
(In fact, many mangroves will, in fact, grow
just fine in fresh water.)
They achieve this partially as they are adapted
to filter with their roots sometimes as much
as 90% of the salt from the water they take
in, which is quite remarkable considering
such strong osmotic pressure would normally
result in water being drawn out of roots rather
than being absorbed.
Any salt the plant does imbibe is then ultimately
excreted through a combination of various
processes, most significantly by the plant
concentrating the salt in older leaves and
bark which will be periodically shed.
So given that many plants, such as trees,
use their leaves and other eventual droppings
as a way to get rid of waste, we'd just like
to explicitly point out that when you're eating
many types of fruit, or drinking that delicious
cup of tea, you're kind of eating and drinking
bits of plant "poop" that are included...
Beyond things shed, many trees also store
waste in their innermost tissues, for instance,
heartwood which is sometimes considered to
be dead upon formation, though some argue
otherwise as it's still able to react chemically
to certain things, such as various organisms
that may cause decay in the tree if introduced.
Nonetheless, this wood no longer plays an
active role in the growth and metabolism of
the tree, making it a safe place to concentrate
waste materials the tree cannot get rid of
other ways, or not get rid of fast enough
elsewise.
In addition, trees may also expel waste through
their roots, as has been observed via introducing
an otherwise toxic substance to a portion
of a tree's roots.
For example, in one such study doing just
this, it was later found that the toxic substance
taken up by certain roots had later been in
turn excreted by the rest.
It should also be noted that, as previously
alluded to, many plants and trees excrete
things in a variety of ways that also very
much have a purpose beyond letting something
build-up within their system.
For many of these things, some don't consider
them akin to poop, while others do, as they
may largely be made up of metabolic waste
or other substances that could be toxic to
the tree if not regularly excreted.
For instance, some plants and trees are known
to intentionally leach harmful waste products
into the surrounding soil or from its leaves
or bark as a defence mechanism.
This can take the form of compounds that kill,
trap, or deter pests from eating the plant,
like latex which among other things does include
chemicals that are toxic to the plant itself.
Some plants, such as the Scots pine, even
produce waste products with antibacterial
properties, helping to protect them from disease.
So in the end, while to some extent whether
trees poop and pee or not, and which mechanisms
constitute doing this, is an argument in semantics,
they do unequivocally expel metabolic waste
and other harmful substances in a variety
of interesting ways- which ones are most analogous
to pooping, peeing, farting or burping, we'll
leave for discussion in the comments.
Bonus Facts:
• At this point you might be wondering whether
carnivorous plants that actually eat living
things pee or poop more like animals.
After all, unlike most plants, these also
take in the bodies of insects and the like.
Do these plants then have to poop this out?
While mechanisms vary, generally speaking
what happens here is that after all the nutrients
are extracted from the living thing, the plant
will simply open back up and allow the remaining
matter to be washed away in the rain or potentially
be blown away by the wind.
Not necessarily a perfect system, however,
waste may still be left in the plant potentially
causing an issue if allowed to continue to
accumulate.
So how is this dealt with?
Often by simply getting rid of the trap mechanism
containing the waste itself.
For example, consider the Venus flytrap- after
a certain number of closures (around 10-12
or, if a successful capture, 3-5 meals or
so) a given trap will no longer respond to
external stimuli and instead will simply perform
its function in photosynthesis before ultimately
being expelled from the plant.
• The fact that trees excrete otherwise
toxic heavy metals as a waste product in their
leaves has very recently been suggested as
a way to find rich gold deposits deep underground
and estimate their concentration, specifically
using certain species of Eucalyptus trees,
which can have amazingly deep taproots, extending
over 40 meters (about 130 feet) deep into
the ground.
In a study published in October of 2013, Natural
gold particles in Eucalyptus leaves and their
relevance to exploration for buried gold deposits,
the researchers found that Eucalyptus trees
growing at the Freddo Gold Prospect in Western
Australia were indeed transporting gold from
far under ground to the surface via taking
it up from its deepest roots, then ultimately
transporting much of the toxic gold to the
leaves (at upwards of 80 parts per billion
accumulating in the leaves vs 44 p.p.b in
the twigs, 4 p.p.b. in the bark, and only
0.1 to 0.7 p.p.b. in the trunk).
Even though most eucalyptus are evergreens,
ultimately the leaves are shed, removing the
toxic substance from the tree, though also
resulting in it accumulating more in the topsoil.
• Speaking of eating tree poop, we also
have the interesting case of figs and you
potentially eating wasp eggs or larvae and
bits of wasp bodies along with the tree poop...
You see, certain types of fig trees have a
symbiotic relationship with wasps, which lay
their eggs inside immature figs and in return
pollinate it.
Fig trees are able to tell when a wasp doesn’t
hold up its end of the bargain and will often
drop an immature fruit containing eggs if
the wasp who laid them doesn’t pollinate
it.
What makes this all even more interesting
is that in some species, the wasp must actively
pollinate the fig tree, rather than it just
being the byproduct of the wasp being covered
in pollen or the like and passively pollinating
the tree.
So if an active-pollinator wasp tries to cheat
the system to save itself a bit of effort,
the fig tree is able to tell that, and rather
than continue to waste resources on such an
unpollinated fruit, it may sacrifice it.
The downside for the wasp, of course, is its
offspring will not survive, also increasing
the likelihood that cheater wasps will be
bred out.
Unsurprisingly from this, it's been discovered
that in fig species where non-pollination
is most heavily sanctioned by the tree, active-pollinator
wasps that will attempt to cheat the system
in this way are much more rare.
(Though there do exist other species of non-pollinating
wasps which are happy to swoop into a pollinated
fruit and lay their eggs inside as well, piggybacking
on the pollinator wasp's efforts.)
And if at this point you're worried about
accidentally eating a wasp body or body parts
when eating a fig, this shouldn't typically
be the case with commercially grown figs,
which usually use species that do not require
pollination.
However, with figs that do require pollination
to grow mature fruit, it is likely in eating
such a fruit that you'll be getting bits of
wing and antenna as the female often loses
these as she bores inside to lay her eggs.
On top of that, once hatched, many species
of male are not capable of flight and instead
simply mate with the female, bore their way
out (providing a path for the young female
to exit) and die, occasionally even dying
inside the fig if it fails to make an exit...